m
très belle cérémonie ce 2 décembre dans
les jardins de la villa du département
ou 20 réunionnais d'exception ont reçu
le prix départemental du mérite
à travers ce prix la collectivité
récompense les efforts de personnes qui
à travers leurs actions contribuent à
faire avancer la société réunionite
modèle de courage et d'insertion des
valeurs il est essentiel de transmettre
aux jeunes générations
le prix de l'excellence mais qui font en
tonnes comme étant le prix de nou lé
kapab on fait plein de choses on connaît
ce que feront ceux qui ont droit à la
télévision aux journaux milliards virés
de nenê ménez qui sont formidables qui
vont plein de chose de quotidien et le
but c'est de montrer aux uns et aux
autres que ces personnes méritent notre
reconnaissance mérite d'être honoré par
le travail mais qui sait aussi d'exemple
pour les autres
aujourd'hui je conseil départemental au
nord ces réunionnais c'est rennaise qui
font avancer
la réunion en donnant beaucoup d'amour à
l'autre le prix départemental du mérite
a été décerné à 20 citoyens avec des
critères de mérite telles que le courage
l'engagement l'humilité ou encore
l'exemplarité des personnes qui évoluent
souvent dans l'ombre pour qui
aujourd'hui ce prix représente une
véritable reconnaissance c'est le
travail reconnu par par les pairs par
les élus donc de mon investissement
mais c'est aussi un travail de
partenariat avec les associations les
parents les athlètes les adversaires
parce qu'il ya eu des adversaires eux
aussi m'ont permis de progresser et que
ça dort du numérique bas c'est sérieux
surtout que je leur dédie cette médaille
je suis très heureuse d'avoir eu ce prix
je m'y attendais pas du tout en fait ce
travail dans l'ombre puisque je suis une
association mais malgré je pense
j'espère que ce prix va pouvoir mourir
dépend qui jusqu'à maintenant sont
fermés c'est si important parce que
c'est une reconnaissance du travail que
je fais
les jours sur le terrain avec mon équipe
c'est important parce que ce que je fais
en essayant de faire l'insertion pour le
chien pour les jeunes de sortir les
personnes âgées de chez elle pour venir
à l'association voilà c'est quelque
chose qui je suis content que ça soit
m'ont connu fille ca me touche beaucoup
pourquoi j'aime honneur parce que je
suis très heureuse que ça madame
beaucoup et que je suis con dans le
désert du sinaï depuis 2006 66 rayonner
ont été distingués dans des domaines
divers tels que l'agriculture
l'artisanat le handicap la famille la
culture ou la vie associative